Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. At 10 minutes past 11 on the night of Saturday November 10, 2012, a loud and frightening sound erupted several miles south of the American city of Indianapolis. The powerful force registered on a regional earthquake sensor, and within minutes, 9-1-1 was jammed with over 500 calls from frantic locals reporting that their homes were left
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本期节目说明。2012年11月10日星期六晚上11点10分，美国印第安纳波利斯市以南几英里处爆发了一声巨大而可怕的巨响。这股强大的力量被区域地震传感器记录下来，几分钟内，911就被来自慌乱的当地人的500多通电话打爆，他们报告说自己的家
rattling from the impact. The noise had originated in Richmond Hill, one of many suburban subdivisions in the Perry Township, 11 miles south of the city. The relatively new middle-class neighborhood was made up of 125 immaculate houses similar in design, single or double-story family homes with brick frontage, gray roofing, vaulted ceilings, and manicured lawns that sat side by side along a small network of streets, bordered on one side by the smock golf course. Emergency services rushed to Richmond Hill and found the area in complete chaos. Properties were in varying states of destruction, windows were shattered, walls cracked or collapsed, doors blown off their hinges, and ceilings caved in.
在冲击波中剧烈摇晃。声音起源于里士满山，这是佩里镇许多市郊分住宅区之一，位于该市以南11英里处。这个相对较新的中产阶级社区由125栋设计相似的完美房屋组成，是一两层带砖砌正面、灰色屋顶、拱形天花板和修剪整齐的草坪的家庭住宅，沿着一小片街道并排坐落，一侧以斯莫克高尔夫球场为界。紧急服务人员赶到里士满山，发现该地区一片混乱。房屋处于不同程度的破坏状态，窗户粉碎，墙壁破裂或倒塌，门被炸飞，天花板塌陷。
Insulation and ash rained down and rubble littered the streets and yards. Panicked residents had gathered on street corners, describing being thrown from their beds, seats, or knocked off their feet by the impact and slammed against furniture or struck by falling debris. Richmond Hill's proximity to a municipal airport led to speculation that a plane had crashed. Others were convinced a bomb had gone off or a clandestine methamphetamine lab had exploded. The level of destruction worsened towards the center of the subdivision, where the apex of the unknown catastrophe was pinpointed to field fairway. At number 8355, 34-year-old Dion Longworth had been on the ground level of his two-story home
绝缘材料和灰烬如雨般落下，瓦砾散落在街道和院子里。惊慌失措的居民聚集在街角，描述说自己被冲击力从床铺、座位上抛出或被撞倒在地，猛烈撞击到家具上或被掉落的碎片砸中。里士满山靠近市政机场，这引发了人们对飞机坠毁的猜测。其他人则确信是炸弹爆炸或地下冰毒实验室发生了爆炸。随着到达位于球道（field fairway）未知灾难顶峰的分区中心，破坏程度越来越严重。在8355号，34岁的迪恩·朗沃思（Dion Longworth）当时正在他两层住宅的一楼
when the forceful impact went off, blasting a hole through the floor and causing him to fall into the basement. He suffered a laceration to his head but was otherwise relatively unscathed. Yet, a fire was advancing and debris prevented his escape. Dion called out from a cavity to the street outside, catching the attention of his fleeing neighbors. They tried to rescue him by chipping away at the plasterboard, but the materials had compressed and wouldn't budge. Dion asked about the welfare of his wife, Jennifer, who had been upstairs. His neighbor didn't know how to break the news that their house no longer had an upstairs. The fire swept through at an alarming speed.
当强烈的冲击爆发时，在地板上炸出一个洞，导致他跌入地下室。他的头部裂伤，但除此之外相对毫发无伤。然而，大火正在蔓延，废墟阻碍了他的逃生。迪恩从一个空腔向外面的街道呼救，引起了逃难邻居的注意。他们试图通过凿碎石膏板来营救他，但材料已经压缩，纹丝不动。迪恩询问楼上的妻子珍妮弗（Jennifer）的安危。他的邻居不知道该如何打破这个噩耗：他们的家已经没有二楼了。大火以惊人的速度蔓延。
A police officer who had arrived to the scene frantically radioed to dispatch. We've got a person trapped in the basement of a house. They're burning. He's trapped in the back. He's screaming. We need to get a hose to the rear as soon as possible. Oh god, I can't get any closer. Firefighters attacked the side of Belongworth's house with an axe, but the heat made it difficult to stay close. Dion remained pressed against the cavity, still pleading to know if his wife was okay. When the firefighters stepped back to spray water towards the space,
一名赶到现场的警察疯狂地用对讲机向调度中心呼叫。我们有一个人被困在房屋地下室里。他们在燃烧。他被困在后面。他在尖叫。我们必须尽快把水带送到后方。哦，天哪，我无法再靠近了。消防员用斧头砍向朗沃思家的侧面，但高温使他们难以靠近。迪恩仍然紧贴着空腔，仍在恳求知道他的妻子是否安好。当消防员退后向该空间喷水时，
the entire house suddenly collapsed. The blaze was under control by the following moment. The blaze was under control by the following moment. The blaze was under control by the following moment. The blaze was under control by the following moment. The blaze was under control by the following moment. The blaze was under control by the following moment. The blaze was under control by the following moment.
整栋房子突然倒塌。大火在接下来的那一刻得到了控制。大火在接下来的那一刻得到了控制。大火在接下来的那一刻得到了控制。大火在接下来的那一刻得到了控制。大火在接下来的那一刻得到了控制。大火在接下来的那一刻得到了控制。大火在接下来的那一刻得到了控制。
The blaze was under control by the following moment. The blaze was under control by the following moment. The blaze was under control by the following moment. The blaze was under control by the following moment. The blaze was under control by the following morning of Sunday, November 11. 80 homes had been damaged, 33 beyond repair. Dion Longworth had been killed along with his 36-year-old wife, Jennifer, who had died in the initial blast while laying in the couple's bed upstairs.
大火在11月11日星期日接下来的早晨得到了控制。80栋房屋受损，33栋无法修复。迪恩·朗沃思与他36岁的妻子珍妮弗双双遇难，珍妮弗在楼上夫妻俩的床上躺着时死于最初的爆炸。
12 other residents sustained injuries, including broken bones, lacerations and smoke inhalation. As the investigation into the tragedy began, a safety command post was established to coordinate the multiple insurance companies and officials that were present, including representatives from the Federal Bureau of Alcohol, Tobacco, Firearms and Explosives and the Department of Homeland Security. The neighborhood was put on lockdown as arson investigators sifted through the rubble, looking for the explosion's point of origin, ruling out possible causes as they went.
其他12名居民受伤，包括骨折、裂伤和吸入浓烟。随着对这起悲剧调查的展开，建立了一个安全指挥所，以协调在场的多个保险公司和官员，其中包括联邦烟酒枪炮及爆炸物管理局和国土安全部的代表。该社区被封锁，纵火调查人员在瓦砾中筛查，寻找爆炸的起因，并在进行过程中排除可能的原因。
The house alongside the Longworths, number 8349 Field Fairway, had sustained the worst damage. It had been completely levelled, with nothing but a pile of ash and debris remaining. Homeowner, 47-year-old intensive care nurse, Montserrati Shirley, lived at the address with her partner, 42-year-old Mark Leonard, and her 12-year-old daughter from a previous marriage. The family were initially unaccounted for, prompting fears they may have been killed. As it turned out, Montserrati and Mark had been 90 miles away at the Hollywood Casino in Lawrenceburg for a weekend getaway, and Montserrati's daughter was staying with a family friend.
与朗沃思家相邻的房屋——菲尔德球道（Field Fairway）8349号受损最严重。它已被完全夷为平地，只剩下成堆的灰烬和瓦砾。房主、47岁的重症监护护士蒙塞拉蒂·希利（Montserrati Shirley）与她的伴侣42岁的马克·伦纳德（Mark Leonard）以及她与前夫所生的12岁女儿住在该地址。这家人最初失踪，引发了他们可能被杀害的担忧。事实证明，蒙塞拉蒂和马克当时在劳伦斯堡的好莱坞赌场度周末，距离这里90英里，而蒙塞拉蒂的女儿正和家庭朋友呆在一起。
The property's gas meter was found amongst the destruction, and displayed a reading twice the amount recorded by the household's gas provider three weeks prior, a volume equivalent to three tons of TNT. When speaking with an investigator, Montserrati and Mark reported that a week before the blast, the distinct rotten egg-like odor of natural gas was permeating throughout their home, which was ice cold, as the furnace was releasing cold air. They contacted the gas company to see if someone could fix it, but decided not to proceed with the appointment as an additional rate applied to weekend call-outs. Mark thought the problem lay with the digital thermostat, so he purchased and installed an older manual model, but it didn't
在废墟中发现了该物业的燃气表，其读数是该家庭燃气供应商三周前记录的金额的两倍，相当于三吨TNT的体积。在与调查人员交谈时，蒙塞拉蒂和马克报告说，在爆炸发生前一周，天然气特有的臭鸡蛋味弥漫了他们的家，家里冰冷，因为暖气炉释放的是冷气。他们联系了燃气公司看是否有人能修好它，但由于周末上门服务要加收额外费用，他们决定不继续预约。马克认为问题出在数字恒温器上，于是购买并安装了一个较旧的手动型号，但并没有
fix the problem, so Montserrati asked him to switch it back the next day. The source of the gas leak was isolated to a fireplace that was originally situated in the family's living room. As per standard building code, the home was fitted with a step-down regulator, a device that reduces the pressure of gas flow to household appliances, but a piece of black pipe had been fitted in its place. The on and off switch for the fireplace was also missing, with toolmarks indicating it had been intentionally removed prior to the explosion. An extensive search of neighbouring properties, rooftops, sewers and cars commenced, but neither the fireplace switch nor the gas regulator were found.
解决问题，于是蒙塞拉蒂要求他在第二天将其换回来。气体泄漏的源头被锁定在最初位于该家庭起居室的壁炉上。根据标准建筑规范，该住宅配有降压器，这是一种将燃气流向家用电器的压力降低的装置，但取而代之的是安装了一段黑色的管道。壁炉的开关也失踪了，上面的工具痕迹表明它在爆炸前被有意移除。对邻近物业、屋顶、下水道和汽车进行了广泛的搜查，但既没有找到壁炉开关，也没有找到燃气调节器。
Experts calculated that it would have taken nine hours for the house to fill with the amount of gas required to cause an explosion of that magnitude, concluding the fireplace was likely turned on at approximately 2pm the day of the blast. A forensic scientist examining aerial photographs of the remnants of the Shirley home concluded from blast patterns that the detonation originated in the kitchen. Found within the rubble was the household's microwave, a General Electric Spacemaker XL model. Its door had been blown off and recovered elsewhere, meaning the appliance had sustained a build-up of pressure from within before exploding, instead of being crushed from falling debris. As no one was home at the time, there was no
专家计算得出，房子充满引发如此规模爆炸所需数量的燃气需要九个小时，并得出结论：壁炉很可能是在爆炸当天下午2点左右被打开的。一名法医检查了希利家残余物的航空照片，根据爆炸模式推断，引爆点起源于厨房。在废墟中发现的是该家庭的微波炉，型号为通用电气太空大师XL（General Electric Spacemaker XL）。它的门被炸飞并在其他地方被找到，这意味着该设备在爆炸前内部承受了压力积聚，而不是被坠落的碎片压碎。由于当时家里没人，因此无法解释
explanation as to why the microwave had been in use. Remarkably, investigators found the appliance's instruction manual and learned that it was fitted with a timer enabling it to be programmed to begin cooking up to 24 hours in advance. A metal cylinder showed evidence of damage indicative of having blown out from inside the microwave. Additionally, concrete samples of the property's foundation revealed gasoline was present in two locations, including the living room where the gas fireplace was located. With all these factors combined, it was clear that the blast had not been an accident. Montserrati Shirley had dreamed of living in Richmond Hill since the subdivision was first developed. She had moved to the United States from Puerto Rico in her early
为什么微波炉一直在使用。值得注意的是，调查人员找到了该设备的使用说明书，并得知它配备了一个定时器，可以对其进行编程，以提前最多24小时开始烹饪。一个金属圆柱体显示出从微波炉内部炸毁的迹象。此外，该物业地基的混凝土样本显示，在两个位置存在汽油，包括位于燃气壁炉所在的起居室。综合所有这些因素，很明显这起爆炸并非意外。自该分区首次开发以来，蒙塞拉蒂·希利就梦想着住在里士满山。她在20岁出头时从波多黎各移居美国，
20s, seeking better employment and financial stability, setting her goal on raising a family in a large home in a nice neighborhood. While completing her nursing degree in Michigan, she fell in love with a pharmaceutical manufacturer named John Shirley, and the two were married shortly thereafter. They relocated to Indiana, and in 2001, Montserrati gave birth to their first and only child. Although Richmond Hill was a little out of their price range, the Shirley's managed to get the bank's financial approval to purchase a block of land in the sought-after location. In 2003, they began building their dream home. A two-story, four-bedroom residence spread over 2,784 square feet, with an attached two-car garage and rear patio for entertaining.
寻求更好的就业和财务稳定，将目标设定在好社区的大房子里抚养家庭。在密歇根州完成护理学位时，她爱上了一家制药公司的制造商约翰·希利（John Shirley），两人不久后结婚。他们搬到了印第安纳州，2001年，蒙塞拉蒂生下了他们的第一个也是唯一的孩子。尽管里士满山稍微超出他们的预算，希利夫妇还是设法获得了银行的财务批准，在备受追捧的地点购买了一块土地。2003年，他们开始建造梦想中的家。这是一栋两层、四居室的住宅，占地2784平方英尺，配有相连的双车位车库和用于娱乐的后露台。
Over the years, John and Montserrati's relationship deteriorated, and in 2011, they filed for divorce. As part of the settlement, Montserrati kept the house, with John agreeing to pay monthly child support and to financially contribute towards school fees. Following her divorce, Montserrati met and began dating Mark Leonard, a dancer turned successful construction worker with several developments and investments in the works that afforded him a luxury lifestyle. There's was a whirlwind romance, and a few weeks after meeting Montserrati, Mark moved into her Richmond Hill home, where they settled into a comfortable, suburban life together. In early 2012, five months into their relationship,
多年来，约翰和蒙塞拉蒂的关系恶化，并于2011年申请离婚。作为协议的一部分，蒙塞拉蒂保留了房子，约翰同意支付每月的子女抚养费，并在经济上分担学费。离婚后，蒙塞拉蒂遇到了马克·伦纳德并开始约会，马克是一名从舞者转型为成功的建筑工人的男子，手头有几个开发项目和投资，为他提供了奢华的生活方式。这是一场旋风般的浪漫，在与蒙塞拉蒂见面几周后，马克搬进了她位于里士满山的家中，在那里他们一起安顿下来，过上了舒适的郊区生活。2012年初，在他们关系开始五个月后，
Mark fell into a coma as a result of a rare autoimmune disease. Montserrati stayed with him as he underwent treatment, and in May, he was finally allowed to return home. She spent the next few months nursing him back to health, and it was only recently that it was back on his feet. The pair had spent the previous three weekends away together, when on their most recent trip, their house exploded, obliterating all their possessions. From Mark's Cadillac STS and Harley Davidson motorcycle to an original Picasso painting, as well as $20,000 cash the family had saved. Just over a week after the Richmond Hill explosion, a funeral service was held for
马克因一种罕见的自身免疫性疾病陷入昏迷。蒙塞拉蒂在他接受治疗期间一直陪着他，5月份，他终于被允许回家。接下来的几个月里，她一直在照顾他恢复健康，直到最近他才重新站起来。两人在过去的三个周末一起外出度假，就在他们最近的一次旅行中，他们的房子爆炸了，将他们所有的财产化为灰烬。从马克的凯迪拉克STS和哈雷戴维森摩托车到毕加索的原画，以及这家人积攒的2万美元现金。里士满山爆炸发生一周多后，举行了一场葬礼
Dion and Jennifer Longworth at St Barnabas Catholic Church, where they had been married 11 years prior. In lieu of caskets, a photo of the couple on their wedding day sat at the altar, along with vases of sunflowers, which were Dion's favorite. Over 500 mourners attended, as Dion was remembered for his quirky sense of humor, creativity, and generosity. As an audio engineer, he helped develop award-winning electronic products for digital sound and video company Indie Audio Labs. Jennifer was a second grade teacher at a nearby elementary school, and was remembered for her compassion and optimism. Monsignor Tony Valls, who oversaw the service, said that the couple had used their wedding vows
迪恩和珍妮弗·朗沃思在圣巴拿马天主教堂（St Barnabas Catholic Church）举行，他们11年前就在那里结婚。在灵柩的代替下，一张这对夫妇婚礼当天的照片摆放在圣坛上，还有几瓶向日葵，这是迪恩最喜欢的花。500多名哀悼者出席，迪恩因其古怪的幽默感、创造力和慷慨而被人们铭记。作为一名音频工程师，他帮助数字声音和视频公司Indie Audio Labs开发了屡获殊荣的电子产品。珍妮弗是附近小学的二年级老师，她以同情心和乐观精神而被人们铭记。主持仪式的托尼·瓦尔斯蒙席（Monsignor Tony Valls）表示，这对夫妇用他们的结婚誓言
to promise to love one another until death, and that now, quote, God has helped them live out their vows. That evening, police announced that the Richmond Hill explosion was officially being treated as a homicide, confident that Dion and Jennifer Longworth had inadvertently lost their lives as a result of a targeted attack on the Shirley household. Through their investigations, a possible suspect had emerged after the discovery of an unlikely survivor of the explosion, a Persian cat named Snowball. The pet belonged to Montserrati Shirley's daughter, and over the past three weekends, including the date of the blast, Montserrati had placed the cat
承诺彼此相爱直到死亡，而现在，引述，“上帝帮助他们兑现了他们的誓言。”那天晚上，警方宣布里士满山爆炸案正式按凶杀案处理，他们确信迪恩和珍妮弗·朗沃思由于对希利一家的有针对性袭击而无辜丧生。通过他们的调查，在发现了一名罕见的爆炸幸存者——一只名叫雪球（Snowball）的波斯猫后，出现了一个可能的嫌疑人。这只宠物属于蒙塞拉蒂·希利的女儿，在过去的三个周末，包括爆炸发生之日，蒙塞拉蒂都把这只猫安置在
in a kennel. This was uncharacteristic of her, as Montserrati wasn't known to board Snowball when away from home. Montserrati and Mark's alibis were checked, with records from the Hollywood Casino confirming the couple checked in the night before the explosion. Their reservation was for one night, and they returned to the front desk in the morning to extend to their stay, but no rooms were available. Instead, the pair remained in the gaming area, with CCTV capturing them playing Blackjack before retiring to the bar where they remained for 11 hours, intermittently checking their phones and watches until receiving news of the explosion. Investigators at the crime scene had also noticed something peculiar when examining the
犬舍里。这不符合她的性格，因为蒙塞拉蒂在离家时并不习惯寄养雪球。蒙塞拉蒂和马克的不在场证明得到了核实，来自好莱坞赌场的记录证实这对夫妇在爆炸前一晚登记入住。他们的预订是一晚，他们在早上回到前台延长住宿时间，但没有房间了。相反，两人留在游戏区，闭路电视捕捉到他们在打二十一点，然后退到酒吧，在那里呆了11个小时，间歇性地查看手机和手表，直到收到爆炸的消息。犯罪现场的调查人员在检查
remains of the Shirley home. Household furniture doesn't disintegrate during an explosion, but smashes into smaller pieces. Yet, for a house that size, there weren't many pieces of furniture strewn about. They found several remote controls and television wall mounts, but no evidence of the electronics themselves. In March the year before, Montserrati had briefly put the house on the market, and the real estate photos were still available online. These images showed the house had been well furnished. A tip-off and subsequent inquiries led police to Mark Leonard's older brother, Bob, who had stored some boxes of clothing, photographs, personal items, and a set of golf clubs in his son's basement. Bob had told his son that the belongings were salvaged from
希利家的残骸时也注意到了一些奇怪的事情。家用家具在爆炸期间不会解体，而是会粉碎成更小的碎片。然而，对于那样大小的房子来说，散落的家具并不多。他们发现了几个遥控器和电视壁挂架，但没有电子产品本身的证据。前一年的三月，蒙塞拉蒂曾短暂将房子挂牌出售，房地产照片仍然可以在网上找到。这些图片显示这房子的家具很齐备。一条线索和随后的调查将警方引向马克·伦纳德的哥哥鲍勃（Bob），他在其儿子的地下室里存放了几箱衣物、照片、个人物品和一套高尔夫球杆。鲍勃告诉他的儿子，这些物品是在爆炸后从希利家中抢救出来的。
the Shirley home following the explosion. Yet, when speaking with detectives, Bob explained that his brother had approached him two weeks before the explosion with the items, claiming they belonged to Montserrati's ex-husband. Bob also reported smelling gas during a visit to the Shirley home, but was uncertain of the source. The couple's friends, relatives, and neighbors were questioned, with one Richmond Hill resident recalling that on the day of the explosion, the blinds at Montserrati's home, which were typically kept open, were pulled down. Another neighbor said that same day he saw Mark Leonard's white work van parked outside the house at approximately 2pm. Two unknown men hastily exited the house before driving away in the van.
然而，在与侦探交谈时，鲍勃解释说，他的哥哥在爆炸前两周带着这些物品找到他，声称它们属于蒙塞拉蒂的前夫。鲍勃还报告说，在访问希利家时闻到了燃气味，但不确定来源。这对夫妇的朋友、亲戚和邻居都受到了讯问，其中一名里士满山居民回忆说，在爆炸当天，蒙塞拉蒂家通常开着的百叶窗被拉下了。另一位邻居说，同一天，他看到马克·伦纳德的白色工作面包车停在房子外面，大约在下午2点。两个陌生人匆忙从房子里出来，然后开着面包车离开。
An acquaintance described Mark as a scam artist who allegedly used online dating sites to meet and seduce older women. He would romance them by picking them up in a nice car, dressing sharply, and taking them to fancy restaurants, where he would then pretend to answer an urgent phone call to discuss a business matter, making it sound as though he had an important construction job in the works. Once the women believed the con, he would ask to borrow money, and would then disappear. Another of his schemes was to take a woman to the casino, and after claiming to have left his wallet at home, convince them to place sizeable bets on his behalf, then keep any winnings. According to Mark, Montserrati was okay with him dating
一位熟人将马克描述为一个骗子，据称他使用约会网站来结识和勾引年长的女性。他会用一辆漂亮的汽车接她们、穿得体面并带她们去高档餐厅来浪漫化她们，在那里他会假装接听一个紧急电话来讨论商业事务，让人觉得他手头有一个重要的建筑工作。一旦这些女性相信了这个骗局，他就会要求借钱，然后就会消失。他的另一个计谋是带女人去赌场，在声称把钱包落在家里后，说服她们代表他下注可观的赌注，然后留住任何赢来的钱。据马克说，蒙塞拉蒂并不介意他跟
other women, as long as the relationships weren't sexual. A background check on Mark Leonard revealed a criminal history that began when he was 18 years old. In addition to criminal charges for cocaine possession and drug dealing, as well as reports of stalking and intimidation, he was being sued by multiple women accusing him of scamming them out of money. He also had a history of insurance fraud related to a car accident. At the time he met Montserrati, Mark was on house arrest, with his movements monitored by a GPS ankle tracker. A relative informed police that another of Mark's scams was to intentionally set off the airbags in his car, then submit a claim with his insurance agency.
其他女人约会，只要这些关系不是性关系。对马克·伦纳德的背景调查显示，他的犯罪史始于他18岁时。除了因持有可卡因和贩毒而受到的刑事指控，以及有关跟踪和恐吓的报告外，他还被多名指控他骗取钱财的女性起诉。他还有与车祸有关的保险诈骗史。在他遇到蒙塞拉蒂时，马克正在软禁中，他的行踪受到GPS脚踝追踪器的监控。一位亲属通知警方，马克的另一个骗局是故意引爆车内的安全气囊，然后向保险公司索赔。
Upon receiving the settlement, he would keep the money instead of replacing the airbags. He had also stolen a truck, insured it in his brother's name, and then set it on fire, pocketing the payout. He owed $77,000 in civil lawsuits, and racked up over $60,000 in unpaid accounts. Three weeks before the explosion, Mark confided in a friend that he had lost $10,000 at the casino. Montserrati's bank records revealed that she had financial trouble of her own. Struggling with their $160,000 mortgage, she and her ex-husband had filed for bankruptcy in 2007, with Montserrati taking responsibility for their outstanding debts as part of their divorce agreement. She had since taken out a second mortgage for $65,000, of which she was three months late making
收到理赔金后，他会把钱留着，而不是更换安全气囊。他还偷了一辆卡车，以他哥哥的名义投保，然后放火烧毁，把理赔金揣进口袋。他欠下了77,000美元的民事诉讼费，并累积了超过60,000美元的未付账单。在爆炸发生前三周，马克向一位朋友吐露，他在赌场输了10,000美元。蒙塞拉蒂的银行记录显示她自己也有财务困难。在他们16万美元的抵押贷款中苦苦挣扎，她和她的前夫于2007年申请破产，蒙塞拉蒂在离婚协议中承担了他们未偿债务的责任。此后，她以65,000美元的价格申请了第二次抵押贷款，其中有三个月逾期未还。
repayments. She had put the home up for short sale in 2011, which meant that it was listed for less than what she currently owed on the mortgage, and she would have to come up with the outstanding money to close the deal, so she eventually decided not to sell and took it off the market. By November 2012, she was $63,000 in credit card debt and still owed $99,000 in bankruptcy repayments, which she had stopped paying. A court hearing had been scheduled in July to address this matter, but Montserrati failed to show. Shortly after Mark Leonard moved in with her in late 2011, she doubled her home contents insurance to $300,000. As suspicions arose around Montserrati and Mark, the press requested interviews and social media
她在2011年将这栋房子进行短售，这意味着它的挂牌价低于她目前在抵押贷款上欠下的钱，她必须筹集未偿还的钱来完成交易，所以她最终决定不出售并将其撤出市场。到2012年11月，她有63,000美元的信用卡债务，并且仍欠99,000美元的破产还款，而她已经停止支付。原定于7月召开听证会来处理此事，但蒙塞拉蒂没有露面。在马克·伦纳德于2011年底搬进来后不久，她将家庭财产保险翻倍至300,000美元。随着对蒙塞拉蒂和马克的怀疑升级，媒体要求采访，社交媒体上
ran rife with rumours about their personal lives. Montserrati told a local news station, I don't wish this on no one. I just want to go to sleep and never wake up. I don't eat. I don't sleep. Everyone's been asking questions. I don't have no financial issues. I'm devastated that I lost it all. My neighbour lost a life. That my whole neighbourhood is destroyed. They need to wait till all of the investigation is done, and I don't want nobody to point a finger to no one. The couple hired a lawyer who issued a statement urging the public to leave his clients alone. It read, The two remain horrified at the tragic events, destruction and loss of lives that occurred.
充斥着关于他们个人生活的谣言。蒙塞拉蒂对当地一家新闻台说：“我不想把这个强加给任何人。我只想去睡觉，再也不醒来。我不吃。我不睡。每个人都在问问题。我没有任何财务问题。我失去了这一切，我感到崩溃。我的邻居失去了生命。我的整个社区都被毁了。他们需要等到所有的调查都完成，我不希望任何人对任何人指指点点。”这对夫妇雇了一位律师，发表了一份声明，敦促公众不要打扰他的客户。其中写道：“两人对发生的悲剧事件、破坏和生命损失仍然感到震惊。
They wish for the causation of this horrific and saddening tragedy to be determined. Assumptions by everyone have had a field day at their expense. They continue to cooperate with authorities and will have no further comments. Investigators were yet to uncover any concrete physical evidence to prove Montserrati Shirley or Mark Leonard had orchestrated the November 10th explosion. GPS trackers were installed on the couple's cars, and their phone calls were covertly monitored, but they failed to uncover anything of significance. A man named Mark Duckworth spoke to police. He was a decade-long friend of Mark Leonard.
他们希望查明这起可怕且令人悲伤的悲剧的起因。大家的假设在他们身上大做文章。他们继续配合当局，将不再发表进一步评论。”调查人员尚未发现任何确凿的物理证据来证明蒙塞拉蒂·希利或马克·伦纳德精心策划了11月10日的爆炸。GPS追踪器被安装在夫妇俩的汽车上，他们的电话也被秘密监控，但未能发现任何有意义的东西。一个名叫马克·杜克沃思（Mark Duckworth）的人对警方说话。他是马克·伦纳德十年之交的朋友。
He recalled a phone conversation wherein Mark mentioned looking at Ferraris online with the intention of buying one. When asked how he could afford it, Mark claimed that tsunami winds had blown out their fireplace, causing their house to blow up, and they had received a $300,000 payout. This conversation occurred eight days before the explosion. Duckworth's statement indicated that Mark and Montserrati had been plotting a scheme for some time. The initial belief was that they had conspired with Mark's brother Bob to enact an elaborate insurance scam, having him visit the property to release the gas and set the microwave timer,
他回忆起一次电话交谈，其中马克提到在网上看法拉利，打算买一辆。当被问及他怎么买得起时，马克声称海啸般的风吹垮了他们的壁炉，导致他们的房子爆炸，他们收到了30万美元的赔偿金。这次谈话发生在爆炸发生前八天。杜克沃思的声明表明，马克和蒙塞拉蒂一段时间以来一直在密谋一个阴谋。最初的看法是，他们与马克的哥哥鲍勃密谋实施了一场精心策划的保险诈骗，让鲍勃参观房产以释放燃气并设置微波炉定时器，
while they were establishing their alibi at the Hollywood Casino. Then, on November 30, an employee for gas company Citizens Energy Group notified police that he ran into the Leonard brothers at a bar on the evening before the explosion. As he was already acquainted with the pair, the three struck up a conversation. Mark and Bob asked about natural gas, inquiring how much was needed to fill up a house. The employee compared it to blowing up a balloon, telling them that at a certain point, there was nothing left for it to do but explode. On December 21, 2012, almost six weeks after the Richmond Hill explosion, Montserrati,
而他们在好莱坞赌场建立不在场证明。然后，在11月30日，燃气公司公民能源集团（Citizens Energy Group）的一名员工通知警方，他在爆炸前一晚在一家酒吧遇到了伦纳德兄弟。由于他已经认识这两人，三人聊了起来。马克和鲍勃询问了天然气，打听填满一栋房子需要多少天然气。该员工将其比作给气球充气，告诉他们到了一定程度，它除了爆炸别无选择。2012年12月21日，在里士满山爆炸发生近六周后，蒙塞拉蒂、
Shirley and Mark Leonard were arrested and served with a 49-count indictment, which included charges for first-degree murder and arson, as well as conspiracy to commit arson and insurance fraud. Their suspected accomplice, Bob Leonard, was also arrested for murder and arson, but was spared the conspiracy charges. Given the severity of their crimes, the trio faced the death penalty. Many residents of Richmond Hill were left unsurprised by the arrests, with one remarking, There were too many circumstantial things that fell into line for it not to have been them, while another said that it was clear from the very beginning that the explosion had not been an
希利和马克·伦纳德被捕，并被控49项罪名，其中包括一级谋杀罪和纵火罪，以及串谋纵火罪和保险诈骗罪。他们涉嫌的同谋鲍勃·伦纳德也被以谋杀和纵火罪逮捕，但免去了串谋指控。鉴于其罪行的严重性，三人面临死刑。里士满山的许多居民对这些逮捕并不感到意外，其中一人评论说：“有太多的间接事情凑巧合在一起，不可能是别人干的，”而另一个人则表示，从一开始就很明显，爆炸并非
accident. On December 24, the trio appeared in court, where they each entered a plea of not guilty. As the arrests occurred just a few days before Christmas, the Richmond Hill community came together to replace some of the possessions Montserrati's 12-year-old daughter had lost in the blast. During the first few months of Mark Leonard's incarceration, he was placed in a cell with Robert Smitty-Smith, a member of an outlaw motorcycle gang and neo-Nati organization. As the soulmates got to know one another, Mark discussed the Richmond Hill explosion. He said the plan had been for his brother to start a fire by cracking a gas line while he and Montserrati were away for the weekend, but Bob had broken the line completely, causing the explosion.
意外。12月24日，三人出庭，他们各自对指控表示不认罪。由于逮捕发生在圣诞节前几天，里士满山社区齐心协力，为蒙塞拉蒂12岁的女儿在爆炸中失去的一些财产进行了替换。在马克·伦纳德入狱的前几个月里，他被关押在一个牢房里，与罗伯特·斯密蒂·史密斯（Robert Smitty-Smith）关在一起，后者是越轨摩托车帮和新纳粹组织的成员。随着这两个灵魂伴侣彼此了解，马克讨论了里士满山爆炸案。他说，计划是他哥哥在周未他和蒙塞拉蒂不在的时候通过撬开燃气管道来纵火，但鲍勃完全弄断了管道，引发了爆炸。
He believed the strongest piece of evidence the prosecutors had against him was Mark Duckworth's statement that he had been shopping for a Ferrari one week before the incident. He was therefore convinced he stood a chance of beating the charges if he could just stop Duckworth from testifying. Mark wrote Smitty a note asking if there was any way he could organize a hit on his friend. The note said that he didn't want Mark Duckworth to quote, show up for court, or show up at all, and offered a payment of $15,000 to make him disappear by staging an accident. A hand drawn map to Duckworth's house was included, along with details about the car he drove. Smitty told Mark that he knew a hitman who would be willing to do the job
他认为检方对他掌握的最有力的证据是马克·杜克沃思的声明，即他在事件发生前一周一直在买法拉利。因此，他确信只要能阻止杜克沃思出庭作证，他就有机会打赢这些指控。马克给斯密蒂写了一张便条，问他是否有办法组织一次对他朋友的暗杀。便条上说，他不想让马克·杜克沃思引述，“出庭，或者根本不出现”，并提供15,000美元的报酬，通过伪造一场事故让他消失。其中包含了一张手绘的杜克沃思家地图，以及他驾驶的汽车的详细信息。斯密蒂告诉马克，他认识一个愿意干这活的杀手，
and the two made plans, with Mark suggesting walking right up to Duckworth's house and shooting him in the kitchen while he was sitting at his computer. Mark expressed hesitancy about using prison telephones to organize the plot, as his calls were being recorded. As Smitty was not subject to the same rules, he gave his personal pin number so Mark could make the calls without being recorded. Mark phoned Smitty's contact, a man identified as Jay. When asked how he wanted the hit to go down, Mark said, why would take a chain and fucking pound it through his fucking groin area and hang him from a tree? He offered Jay a $5,000 bonus if he could force Duckworth to call 911 and to retract the information he had previously given to police by saying,
两人制定了计划，马克建议直接走到杜克沃思家，在他坐在电脑前时在厨房枪杀他。马克对使用监狱电话组织阴谋表示犹豫，因为他的通话正在被录音。由于斯密蒂不受相同规则的约束，他给出了他的个人密码，以便马克可以拨打电话而不被录音。马克打电话给斯密蒂的联系人，一个被识别为杰伊（Jay）的男人。当被问及他希望如何进行谋杀时，马克说：“为什么不拿一条链子，他妈的把它砸进他他妈的腹股沟区域，然后把他挂在树上？”他向杰伊提供5,000美元的奖金，如果他能强迫杜克沃思拨打911，并撤回他之前向警方提供的信息，说：
I did not mean to frame Mark and Montserrati for their own house in Richmond Hill. He ended up asking Jay to make it look like Duckworth had taken his own life, wanting the job done quickly without pausing any unnecessary suffering, as that would take too much time. Jay told him that he enjoyed torturing his victims, to which Mark laughed and responded, well, if you wanna. Unbeknownst to Mark, he was actually conspiring the assassination with an undercover special agent from the Bureau of Alcohol, Tobacco, Firearms and Explosives. Furthermore, his cellmate Smitty was actually a police informant. The phone conversations with Jay were recorded, including Mark stating he wanted another undisclosed target killed
“我不是故意陷害马克和蒙塞拉蒂他们自己在里士满山的房子的。”他最终要求杰伊让杜克沃思看起来像是自己了结了生命，希望快点把工作干完，不要有任何不必要的痛苦，因为那会花太多时间。杰伊告诉他，他喜欢折磨他的受害者，马克对此笑了笑并回答说：“好吧，如果你想的话。”马克不知道的是，他实际上是在与来自烟酒枪炮及爆炸物管理局的卧底特工密谋暗杀。此外，他的狱友斯密蒂实际上是一名警方线人。与杰伊的通话被录音了，包括马克表示希望在针对杜克沃思的暗杀完成后，杀死另一个未公开的目标。
once the hit on Duckworth was complete. Mark Leonard was additionally charged with conspiracy to commit murder, to which he pled not guilty. In August 2013, Montserrati surely filed documents placing a majority of the blame on the Leonard brothers, saying that Mark had been abusive and manipulative throughout their relationship. Two months later, it was decided that the three defendants would all be tried separately outside Marion County to ensure an impartial jury. The death penalty was also taken off the table and replaced with life in prison without parole. To mark the one year anniversary of the Richmond Hill tragedy, faculty members and students at the elementary school where Jennifer Longworth taught second grade wore Indianapolis Colts merchandise
马克·伦纳德还被追加指控串谋谋杀，对此他表示不认罪。2013年8月，蒙塞拉蒂·希利提交了文件，将主要责任归咎于伦纳德兄弟，称马克在他们的关系中一直具有虐待性和操纵性。两个月后，决定这三名被告都将在马里昂县（Marion County）以外分开审判，以确保陪审团公正无私。死刑也被取消，取而代之的是终身监禁且不得假释。为了纪念里士满山悲剧一周年，珍妮弗·朗沃思教二年级的小学的教职员工和学生穿着印第安纳波利斯小马队的商品
in tribute of the Longworth's favorite football team and held a minute silence. Richmond Hill residents were undergoing counseling and still had trouble coping with loud noises. One resident reported struggling to get to sleep as she was haunted by images of blood soaked people running from the neighborhood. Quote, it was hard to get over. It was hard to get those images out of my head. Many expected that at least one of the accused would strike a plea deal, but as the years went by, this seemed less likely. Then in January 2015, Montserrati's defense lawyers approached the prosecution team with an offer. In exchange for dropping the murder charges, their client would agree to plead guilty to the less serious charge of conspiracy to commit
向朗沃思最喜欢的足球队致敬，并默哀一分钟。里士满山居民正在接受心理辅导，并且仍然难以应对巨响。一名居民报告说，由于脑海中挥之不去满身是血的人从社区逃跑的画面，她很难入睡。引述，“很难释怀。很难把那些画面从我的脑海中抹去。”许多人预计至少有一名被告会达成认罪协议，但随着时间的推移，这似乎不太可能。然后，在2015年1月，蒙塞拉蒂的辩护律师带着一项提议接近了检方团队。作为放弃谋杀指控的交换，他们的客户同意对情节较轻的串谋纵火罪认罪，
arson and in return reveal the truth about the explosion and testify against her accomplices. The prosecution was torn. Montserrati's cooperation would help clarify the unexplained details of the crime and settle their suspicions whether any other people were involved. Yet Montserrati had been a key player in the plot and they wanted to see her justly punished. Deputy prosecutor Denise Robinson, quote, she was too involved. She was the one who got her daughter and her cat out of the situation and to left her neighbors in the situation. While we knew that Montserrati surely on her own would never have caused this crime, it could not have happened without her.
并作为回报，说出关于爆炸的真相并指证她的同伙。检方陷入了纠结。蒙塞拉蒂的配合将有助于澄清犯罪中未解释的细节，并解决他们对是否有其他人参与的怀疑。然而，蒙塞拉蒂是阴谋中的关键人物，他们希望看到她受到公正的惩罚。副检察官丹尼斯·罗宾逊（Denise Robinson）引述：“她卷入得太深了。她是那个把女儿和猫带离现场却把邻居留在现场的人。虽然我们知道蒙塞拉蒂·希利靠她自己永远不会犯下这起罪行，但没有她，这一切不可能发生。”
Eventually, the prosecution agreed to the deal, much to the disapproval of Richmond Hill's community who wanted to see their former neighbor given the maximum sentence of life without parole. On January 20, Montserrati started talking. Within weeks of moving into Richmond Hill, Mark Leonard suggested Montserrati double her home contents insurance stating he wanted to buy expensive items and to begin renovations. He also convinced her to sell her car so that he could replace it with a luxury BMW but ended up getting her a dated Ford Taurus instead which cost him only $700. At this point, Mark's true character began to unravel. He wasn't the high roller he made himself
最终，检方同意了这项交易，这遭到了里士满山社区的强烈反对，他们希望看到他们以前的邻居被判处不得假释的终身监禁的最高刑罚。1月20日，蒙塞拉蒂开始开口了。在搬进里士满山几周后，马克·伦纳德建议蒙塞拉蒂将她的家庭财产保险加倍，声称他想买昂贵的物品并开始装修。他还说服她卖掉她的车，以便他可以用一辆豪华宝马取而代之，但最终给她买了一辆过时的福特金牛座（Ford Taurus），只花了他700美元。此时，马克的真实性格开始暴露。他并不是他所表现出来的
out to be. After the explosion, he told blossom judicators he owned a premium condition Cadillac and Tali Davidson motorcycle. In reality, he had a beat up Cadillac he had purchased by selling stolen supplies and equipment from his construction sites and his motorcycle was undrivable. In early 2012, Mark's gambling habits led him to consider committing insurance fraud by setting a small fire in the garage. His friend, Gary Thompson, had done the same and gotten away with it. He had also helped another man named Glenn Holtz carry out a similar act. In July 2012, Mark urged Glenn to convince Montserrati how easy it was. Glenn warned the pair to be careful as he knew someone who had been sentenced to 75 years imprisonment
那种大款。爆炸后，他告诉盲目的审判官，他拥有一辆状况极佳的凯迪拉克和塔利·戴维森（Tali Davidson）摩托车。实际上，他有一辆破旧的凯迪拉克，那是他通过出售建筑工地的偷来物资和设备买的，他的摩托车根本开不了。2012年初，马克的赌博习惯导致他考虑通过在车库里纵小火来实施保险诈骗。他的朋友加里·汤普森（Gary Thompson）曾这样做并逃脱了惩罚。他还曾帮助另一个人格伦·霍尔茨（Glenn Holtz）实施了类似的行为。2012年7月，马克敦促格伦说服蒙塞拉蒂这有多容易。格伦警告两人要小心，因为他认识一个因纵火而被判处75年监禁的人。
for arson. As Montserrati had no criminal history or prior insurance claims, Mark was confident they would get away with it but promised to take the blame if they were caught. Montserrati surely, quote, I thought it was crazy but I went along with him. Mark revisited the scam towards the end of October 2012. Gary Thompson had agreed to help but they just needed Montserrati's approval. Although she wasn't entirely sure what the plan entailed, she gave the green light. On the weekend of October 27, she boarded Snowball at a canal, sent her daughter to stay with a friend, loaded her valuable and sentimental items into Mark's van and the pair checked in to Hollywood Casino. Mark had offered Gary $5,000 to dump six large
由于蒙塞拉蒂没有犯罪记录或先前的保险索赔，马克确信他们会逃脱惩罚，但承诺如果被抓住，他会承担责任。蒙塞拉蒂·希利，引述，“我觉得这太疯狂了，但我还是顺从了他。”马克在2012年10月底重新审视了这个骗局。加里·汤普森同意帮忙，但他们只需要蒙塞拉蒂的批准。虽然她并不完全确定该计划涉及什么，但她开了绿灯。在10月27日的周末，她把雪球寄养在犬舍里，把女儿送到朋友家，把她的贵重物品和有纪念意义的物品装进马克的面包车，两人入住了好莱坞赌场。马克曾向加里提供5,000美元，让他在蒙塞拉蒂家里倾倒六大罐
cans of gasoline inside Montserrati's house but he panicked and couldn't go through with it. He was supposed to call Mark and Montserrati when the job was done but they never heard from him. The next morning, they drove to Gary's house and he lied to the pair about having to call the whole thing off after being pulled over by the police on his way to Richmond Hill. Convinced Gary was flaking, Mark enlisted the help of his brother Bob offering him $10,000 to start the fire. The second attempt was scheduled for the weekend of November 3. In the lead-up, Mark and Gary blocked off the chimney and filled the fireplace with cardboard. They replaced the digital thermostat with a cheaper manual model and had discussions about
汽油，但他恐慌了，无法继续下去。他本应该在工作完成后打电话给马克和蒙塞拉蒂，但他们从未听到他的消息。第二天早上，他们开车去了加里的家，他向两人撒谎说自己在去里士满山的路上被警察拦下后不得不取消整件事。确信加里在打退堂鼓，马克寻求他哥哥鲍勃的帮助，向他提供10,000美元来放火。第二次尝试定于11月3日的周末。在此之前，马克和加里封锁了烟囱，并在壁炉里塞满了纸板。他们用更便宜的手动型号替换了数字恒温器，并讨论了
programming the microwave in advance with a piece of metal inside. Mark turned on the fireplace's gas valve and his brother Bob was expected to visit the home later to tinker with the thermostat to cause it to spark and start a fire. But the plan failed for a second time. The Leonard Brothers went to the library and researched the cause of house fires. Afterwards, they went for a drink at the bar where they ran into an acquaintance who worked for Citizens Energy Group and asked him about natural gas. Glenn Holtz tried to deter Mark, expressing the possibility he was going to blow up the whole neighborhood. Montserrati also begged him to call the whole thing off, offering him the $10,000 in her retirement
在里面放一块金属提前对微波炉进行编程。马克打开了壁炉的燃气阀，他的哥哥鲍勃预计稍后会去家里摆弄恒温器，使其产生火花并引发火灾。但该计划第二次失败了。伦纳德兄弟去图书馆研究了房屋火灾的原因。之后，他们去酒吧喝了一杯，在那里遇到了一个在公民能源集团工作的熟人，并向他询问了天然气。格伦·霍尔茨试图阻止马克，表达了他可能会炸毁整个社区的可能性。蒙塞拉蒂也恳求他取消整件事，并向他提供她退休金里的10,000美元。
fund. But Mark was set on the six-figure insurance payout. On November 9, 2012, before the couple left for the Hollywood casino, they gave Bob Leonard $40 for a part needed to carry out the crime. Just after 11 p.m. the next day, Montserrati received word of the explosion and returned to Richmond Hill, where her and Mark discovered the magnitude of damage, injuries, and deaths it had caused. Police questioned 44-year-old Gary Thompson, who admitted involvement in the scheme and corroborated Montserrati's version of events. Although adamant that he was nowhere near filled fair way the day of the explosion, police were convinced he set the timer on the microwave. Consequently, on January 29, 2015, Gary was arrested and faced over 40 charges,
但马克一心只想要那笔六位数的保险金。2012年11月9日，这对夫妇动身前往好莱坞赌场前，给了鲍勃·伦纳德40美元用来购买实施犯罪所需的零件。第二天晚上11点刚过，蒙特塞拉蒂就收到了爆炸的消息并赶回里士满山，她和马克在那里发现了爆炸造成的严重破坏、人员受伤和死亡情况。警方盘问了44岁的加里·汤普森，他承认参与了该计划，并证实了蒙特塞拉蒂对事件经过的说法。尽管他坚称自己在爆炸当天根本不在菲尔德·费尔韦附近，但警方确信是他设置了微波炉上的定时器。因此，2015年1月29日，加里被捕并面临40多项指控，
including two counts of murder, arson, and conspiracy to commit arson. Glenn Holtz was also interviewed by the police. He denied having any recollection of the conversation in July 2012 about setting Montserrati's house on fire. Police checked Glenn's phone records, which showed 10 calls and text messages between himself and Mark Leonard during the first two weeks of November 2012. On April 14, 2015, Glenn was arrested for conspiracy to commit arson, becoming the fifth arrest in the Richmond Hill explosion case. On Monday, June 8, 2015, Mark Leonard's trial commenced in the County Courthouse in South Bend, Indiana. His defense team admitted that while he had been part of the arson plot, he never
包括两项谋杀罪、纵火罪以及串谋纵火罪。格伦·霍尔茨也受到了警方盘问。他否认自己对2012年7月关于火烧蒙特塞拉蒂房屋的对话有任何记忆。警方查阅了格伦的通话记录，显示在2012年11月的前两周内，他与马克·伦纳德之间有10次通话和短信往来。2015年4月14日，格伦因涉嫌串谋纵火被捕，成为里士满山爆炸案中第五个被捕的人。2015年6月8日星期一，马克·伦纳德的审判在印第安纳州南本德的县法院开庭。他的辩护团队承认，虽然他参与了纵火阴谋，但他从未
foresaw the power of the explosion and had no intention of damaging other properties or hurting anyone. They labelled it as, quote, a stupid and selfish insurance fraud that went horribly wrong. They called Montserrati a master liar who was fully in on the plan from the outset. The prosecution argued that Mark knew that the entire house would be destroyed, as he had advised Montserrati to remove her belongings and relocate her daughter and cat. Furthermore, telling his friend, Mark Duckworth, that he was expecting an insurance payout of $300,000 indicated he expected the house and its possessions to be a complete right-off. Given that he understood the potential severity of the explosion, the prosecution urged the jury to
预见到爆炸的威力，也无意破坏其他财产或伤害任何人。他们将其称为“一起极其荒谬且自私的、彻底搞砸的保险诈骗”。他们称蒙特塞拉蒂是一个从一开始就完全参与计划的撒谎大王。控方则辩称，马克明知整栋房子都会被毁，因为他曾建议蒙特塞拉蒂搬走她的私人物品，并转移她的女儿和猫。此外，马克告诉他的朋友马克·达克沃斯，他预计能获得30,0000美元的保险赔偿，这表明他预料到房子及其里面的财物会彻底报废。鉴于他了解爆炸可能造成的严重后果，控方敦促陪审团
find him guilty of murder, as he knew his scheme came with the high probability of death. The five-week trial saw the submission of over 2,000 pieces of evidence and the testimony of hundreds of witnesses, including Montserrati Shirley as part of her plea deal. She said she went along with her boyfriend's plan because, quote, I was scared. I loved him so much. I would do anything to make him happy. Outside court, Mark's defense attorney told reporters she can tell the truth just as easily as she can tell a lie, and it's hard for the jury to know the difference. During closing remarks, prosecutor Mark Hollingsworth said, every single victim in this case is a victim because of him. Every single co-conspirator
判定他犯有谋杀罪，因为他明知自己的计划极有可能导致死亡。为期五周的审判提交了2000多件证据，并有数百名证人出庭作证，其中包括作为认罪协议一部分的蒙特塞拉蒂·希尔迪。她说，她之所以顺从男友的计划，是因为“我很害怕。我太爱他了。我愿意做任何事来让他开心。”在法庭外，马克的一位辩护律师对记者说，她撒谎就像说真话一样容易，陪审团很难分辨真假。在结案陈词中，检察官马克·霍林斯沃思说，本案中的每一个受害者都是因为他而成为受害者的。本案中的每一个共谋者
in this case would not be charged, but for him. It all comes back to Mark Leonard. On July 14, 2015, after four hours of deliberation, Mark Leonard was found guilty of all 53 counts. Outside court, Jennifer Longworth's father, Don, told reporters the conviction was the closest thing his family would ever get to justice, saying, my wife always talks about what she won't have with her daughter, you know, going shopping and taking care of her kids and all of these things. We won't have any of that. As far as I'm concerned, the Leonard gang sentenced my family to outdoor prison for the rest of our lives. I grieve for my daughter every day, and tomorrow I will go back to the cemetery and knock the grass
若不是因为他，都不会被起诉。这一切都要归咎于马克·伦纳德。2015年7月14日，经过四个小时的审议，马克·伦纳德被裁定所有53项罪名成立。法庭外，珍妮弗·朗沃思的父亲唐对记者说，这次定罪是他的家人最接近正义的一次，他说：“我妻子总是谈论她和女儿无法共同拥有的东西，你知道的，比如去购物、照顾她的孩子以及所有这些事情。我们再也无法拥有这些了。在我看来，伦纳德一伙判处我的家人在余生中遭受精神上的无期徒刑。我每天都为女儿感到悲痛，明天我还会去墓地，像每周一样把坟墓上的草拔掉，然后立刻回到生活中。”
off the grave like I do every week, and get right back to business. Deion Longworth's father, John, said the jury had made the right choice, adding, this doesn't change anything. It means he won't hurt anybody else outside of prison. But Deion and Jennifer are still not with me. During Mark Leonard's sentencing hearing a month later, Deion Longworth's mother, Elaine, gave an emotional statement. She said, I hate that it had to be my boy who lived the next door to Mark and Montserrati. I hate that they were nothing but collateral damage to them. I hate like hell that my brilliant son was brought down by such fools. I absolutely and
戴恩·朗沃思的父亲约翰表示，陪审团做出了正确的选择，并补充说：“这改变不了什么。这只能说明他在监狱外再也不会伤害任何人了。但戴恩和珍妮弗依然不在我身边。”一个月后，在马克·伦纳德的量刑听证会上，戴恩·朗沃思的母亲伊莱恩发表了一番令人动容的陈词。她说：“我恨这扇门外住着马克和蒙特塞拉蒂的人竟然是我的儿子。我恨他们对马克和蒙特塞拉蒂来说只是微不足道的牺牲品。我该死的恨我的天才儿子竟然被这样一群蠢货给害死了。我绝对且
completely hate that my smart, strong, curious, kind, hilarious, and hardworking son died at such an absurdly young age and in such a horrible way. I hate that the ashes of my son and his wife share the space of a sealed box not much bigger than a gallon of milk. I hate that his tortured last moments come to me in flashbacks. I so very much hate it was not me that died, instead of him. Upon handing down his sentence, Judge John Manoka said, a person ought to feel safe in their own home. I know there will be natural disasters, and I know there will be burglaries and thefts, unfortunately, but I think people shouldn't have to worry that someone might destroy the entire neighborhood.
彻底地恨我的儿子那么聪明、坚强、好奇、善良、幽默、努力，却在如此荒谬的年轻时以如此可怕的方式死去。我恨我儿子的骨灰和妻子的骨灰竟然装在一个比一加仑牛奶大不了多少的密封盒里。我恨他临终前饱受折磨的最后时刻总是在我脑海中闪现。我太恨死去的那个人不是我，而是他了。”法官约翰·马诺卡在宣判时说：“一个人应该在自己的家中感到安全。我知道会有自然灾害，我也知道不幸会发生入室盗窃和偷盗，但我认为人们不应该担心有人会毁掉整个社区。”
Mark Leonard received two life sentences without parole. Six months later, on January 21, 2016, Mark's brother Bob Leonard was tried in Fort Wayne, Indiana, with over 150 witnesses called to testify. When Montserrati took the stand, she explained that upon hearing of Deon and Jennifer Longworth's deaths, she didn't want any of the insurance money. Bob allegedly responded with indifference, saying, oh well, they died. The jury found him guilty of all 51 charges. He was sentenced to two life terms without parole. Gary Thompson's trial was scheduled for later that year, but in August, he agreed to plead guilty to conspiracy to commit arson in exchange for having all other
马克·伦纳德被判处两个不得假释的无期徒刑。六个月后的2016年1月21日，马克的弟弟鲍勃·伦纳德在印第安纳州韦恩堡受审，传唤了150多名证人出庭作证。当蒙特塞拉蒂出庭作证时，她解释说，在听说戴恩和珍妮弗·朗沃思夫妇的死讯后，她不想要任何保险金。鲍勃据称对此反应冷漠，说道：“哦，好吧，他们死了。”陪审团裁定他所有51项罪名成立。他被判处两个不得假释的无期徒刑。加里·汤普森的审判原定于当年晚些时候进行，但在8月，他同意就串谋纵火罪认罪，条件是撤销对他所有的其他
charges against him dropped. He was subsequently sentenced to 30 years in prison, with 10 suspended. Bob Leonard called a local television station from prison to voice his disdain at the deal, saying, Gary Thompson was in on this whole thing from start to finish. In late December 2016, Glenn Holtz also entered an agreement with the prosecution. Pleading guilty to one count of assisting a criminal in exchange for having the conspiracy to commit arson charge dropped. He admitted to knowing about the arson plot beforehand and not doing anything to stop it. He was sentenced to three years in prison, for which he only served 18 months. Given that Montserrati surely had reached a plea agreement with the prosecution,
指控。随后，他被判处30年监禁，其中缓刑10年。鲍勃·伦纳德从监狱给当地一家电视台打电话，表达他对这起交易的不满，他说：“加里·汤普森从头到尾都参与了整件事。”2016年12月下旬，格伦·霍尔茨也与控方达成了协议。他承认一项协助犯罪分子的罪名，条件是撤销串谋纵火的指控。他承认自己事先知道纵火阴谋，却没有采取任何行动来阻止。他被判处三年监禁，实际上只服刑了18个月。鉴于蒙特塞拉蒂·希尔迪已与控方达成认罪协议，
she was spared a trial. Instead, her sentencing hearing was held where her family and defense team requested leniency on the basis that Mark Leonard was emotionally abusive, leading to Montserrati's compliance. Her neighbors disputed this, arguing that she was a greedy person, obsessed with portraying a wealthy image. Multiple victim impact statements were read, including one from Dion Longworth's father, John, who said, It's kind of weird to think that you're going about your life and someone has a target on your back, and they don't care. That's one thing I've never seen from any of these defendants. Much caring. She protected her child and cat, but she showed no concern for anyone
她免于受审。取而代之的是举行了量刑听证会，她的家人和辩护团队以马克·伦纳德对其进行情感虐待、导致蒙特塞拉蒂顺从为由请求宽大处理。她的邻居们对此提出异议，认为她是一个贪婪的人，痴迷于塑造富有的人气形象。法庭宣读了多份受害者影响陈述，其中包括戴恩·朗沃思的父亲约翰的一份陈述，他说：“一想到你过着自己的生活，却有人在背后把枪口对准你，而且他们根本不在乎，这种感觉真的很诡异。这是我从这些被告身上从未看到的东西。有一点关心。她保护了自己的孩子和猫，却没有对邻居表现出丝毫的关切。
else in the neighborhood. She traded the lives of our children for her own. Upon delivering her sentence, Judge Sheila Carlile said to Montserrati, You were a mom. You were a nurse. You were a neighbor. And you were a friend. And in each of those categories, you betrayed your trust. Montserrati surely was sentenced to 50 years in prison. She will be eligible to apply for parole in December 2032, aged 72 years old. One month later, Mark Leonard was tried separately for his attempt to hire a hitman to kill his friend, Mark Duckworth, to ensure he couldn't testify against him at trial. The court found him guilty of conspiracy to commit murder, and he received
她用我们孩子的生命换取了她自己的生命。”法官希拉·卡赖尔在宣布判决时对蒙特塞拉蒂说：“你是一位母亲。你是一名护士。你是一个邻居。你还是一个朋友。而在每一个身份中，你都背叛了你的信任。”蒙特塞拉蒂·希尔迪被判处50年监禁。她将于2032年12月获得假释申请资格，届时她将72岁。一个月后，马克·伦纳德因试图雇用杀手谋杀他的朋友马克·达克沃斯（以确保他在审判中无法指证自己）而接受单独审判。法院裁定他犯有谋杀未遂罪，并被判处
an additional 50 years on top of his life sentences. He lodged numerous appeals, but each was rejected. In late January 2018, Mark was transferred to hospital to undergo treatment for his autoimmune disease. On January 30, the Indiana Department of Corrections released a statement announcing that he had died of natural causes. Upon learning of his brother's death, Bob Leonard said, I've only been in trouble twice in my life, and both times were his fault. I couldn't care less that he's dead. I don't have a bit of sympathy for that son of a bitch. In the years following the Richmond Hill explosion, residents reported experiencing ongoing trauma. A third of the families moved away from the subdivision, with six marriages ending in
在无期徒刑的基础上额外增加50年刑期。他提出了无数次上诉，但均被驳回。2018年1月底，马克被转往医院接受自身免疫性疾病的治疗。1月30日，印第安纳州惩教部发表声明，宣布他因自然原因死亡。得知哥哥的死讯后，鲍勃·伦纳德说：“我一生中只惹过两次麻烦，两次都是他的错。他死了我一点也不在乎。我对那个王八蛋没有半点同情心。”在里士满山爆炸案发生后的几年里，居民们报告说经历了持续的精神创伤。三分之一的家庭搬离了该分户小区，其中有六段婚姻以
divorce. To honor their memory, a scholarship titled the Southwest Elementary Jennifer and Deion Longworth Memorial Award was established in 2012, issued to one of her former second grade students each year upon their eventual graduation from high school. A press release by the school said the scholarship would serve as a legacy for Jennifer's excellence in education and allow her former students to carry on her love of learning. Quote, Jennifer had a way of reaching students like no other teacher, students who were tough to reach. She set the expectations on day one of school, and she got results. She loved her kids. As the Longworths were passionate supporters of the Indianapolis Colts football team, the team's owner Jim Ursay was the first
离婚告终。为了纪念他们，2012年设立了一项名为“西南小学珍妮弗与戴恩·朗沃思纪念奖”的奖学金，每年颁发给她以前的一位二年级学生，供其最终高中毕业时使用。学校发布的新闻稿称，该奖学金将成为珍妮弗卓越教育成就的传承，并让她的前学生能够继续她对学习的热爱。“引言：珍妮弗有一种无与伦比的触及学生的方式，包括那些难以接近的学生。她在开学第一天就设定了期望，并且取得了成果。她爱她的孩子。”由于朗沃思夫妇是印第安纳波利斯小马队橄榄球队的狂热支持者，该球队的老板吉姆·厄塞成为第一个
person to make a donation to the fund. Deion was an enthusiastic gardener with an extensive knowledge of native wildflowers and a particular love of sunflowers. He took pride in a hybrid pear tree he planted in their yard on Field Fairway, which continues to grow to this day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
向该基金捐款的人。戴恩是一位热心的园丁，对本土野花有着渊博的知识，尤其喜爱向日葵。他为自己在菲尔德·费尔韦的院子里种植的一棵杂交梨树感到自豪，这棵树至今仍在生长。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。